So, the last stage of life is of course death. Now, it's sobering to think
about, but we're all going to to die and we all know we're going to die.
Different people respond to death in different ways. These differences are best
seen in cases where people know that they're going to die in advance and have
time to prepare for it. For example, someone with a terminal illness. The
psychologist Elisabeth K端bler-Ross developed the most widely known and applied
psychological model of people's response to death. People go through
predictable stages with their own death. Most people go through all of these
stages, but some stages may be more intense than others. The five stages are
denial, anger, bargaining, depression and acceptance.